now there's a lot of people in my chat
that want me to teach you stafford
which is like my favorite favorite
gambit of all time
um it's a very specific
variation which you can't get every
single time with that you're black but
you can get a decent amount and uh
there's a ton of tricks and if you were
like if you were intrigued by the danish
with the fact that you're like giving
away material to get activity yeah
the stafford is at least five times more
venomous like it's super trappy
all right you've sold me already i'm
absolutely sold
okay beautiful so you'd say no more it
starts with e4
most commonly in chess you play e5 you
copy
okay actually what do you usually do
you just i i i i abort and wait for
another game oh you yeah
i'm just kidding yeah i probably just
copy yeah gotcha okay so yeah it's the
most classical move
yep um the first couple moves you are
going to copy so white's going to play
in f3
now most common here is actually to play
knight c6 defending the pawn
but yes you copy with a counter attack
f6 um
now most players will take the pawn on
e5
and we can address other options if they
don't take the pawn you can't quite get
a stafford but
most likely they'll take the pawn
and this is where you stop copying um
now i want to show you how a lot of
like beginner players go wrong here
where if you continue to copy
and you take on e4 you can get into a
lot of trouble
because white will play queen e2
and like if you copy white will take and
defend the knight and that's it's not
great for you so
um but you're already in trouble here if
you move your knight back
then white's gonna unleash some
syntactic knight c6 it's
check and you're losing your queen yeah
it's pretty disgusting
so this is like a very very classic kind
of beginner opening trap that you you
don't want to fall into
um so what you're going to do here
rather than winning back the pawn you're
going to
play knight c6 offering a trade
at first this looks completely fine for
white which it is
um but it's basically the start of the
stafford
uh most times light will take
now do you remember the rule i gave you
earlier of like when you have two pawns
that
can capture what you go for the middle
or
you want to capture towards the center
in this case you're going to violate
that backwards
you want to open the queen file for
something i assume yeah not only opening
the file for the queen but opening the
diagonal for your bishop
and the whole point of this opening
you're accelerating your development
at the cost for for giving away the pawn
so even though you lost your center pawn
and your pawns are doubled you have one
more piece developed and your pieces are
ready to come out very quickly
um and this is really the starting
position like if you're able to get this
position
this is the beginning of the staffer
gambit
and there's a few different ways white
can respond
but a few rules to keep in mind
almost always your bishop will develop
here
and the f2 pawn for white will be a big
target
and we'll see a bunch of examples of how
you can win
very very quickly by targeting f2 pawn
very often in conjunction with knight g4
so one one of the main moves for white
is
is d3 now we'll start by by going
through some of the
the main traps so imagine d3 you'll
you'll play bishop c5
and let's imagine white plays bishop g5
i'm starting with this one because it's
one of the most beautiful
staffer gambit traps where um it was one
of the things that inspired me to play
this opening initially
you go queen d4 so queen d4 it's
it's actually probably one of the best
moves but there's an even stronger
and more beautiful move queen d4 would
be a fork
and yeah you would win back some win
back at least a pawn
um the move to play here
it looks really bad at first i'm just
going to show it to you because
it's kind of hard to find but i'll have
you try and like understand
it is knight takes e4
breaking the pin your light was pinned
to your queen
yeah um
and most often light will take your
queen queen yeah so what's the point how
do you how do you continue
well i mean the only logical move you
have left is taking the
f pawn with one of the two pieces
otherwise there's nothing else makes
sense exactly
so which which do you take with the
knight or the bishop
i feel like if you take with a knight
you're not giving check so you're just
gonna move his king and re-stabilize
with the queen advantage so it has to be
the bishop for some reason i just don't
know why
yeah you're on the right track um it's
what we call a forcing move when you
take with bishop
you're forcing white to get out of check
move forward once
white has only legal move king e2
yes and then how to continue
i guess you check with the other bishop
because the only check you have
it's like a puzzle almost yeah yeah no
it's uh
it's exactly like a checkmating puzzle
and when you
when you play bishop g4 it's not only
check oh it's
but it's it's meat it's made oh wow it
is mate
it is it's also a skewer yeah it's
a lot of things in one i didn't even see
the mate i just
yeah that's crazy yeah it's funny like
when you play this movie
you just see the queen and king and
queen the line you assume you're winning
back a queen but yeah it's just game
over
yeah it's amazing how the black pieces
coordinate too
because the bishop covers e1 the knight
defends the bishop covers e3 and that
covers the square
so minor pieces coordinate perfectly
taking away all the squares around the
king
um that is great yeah and this is one of
the most common
traps people will walk into because it's
so natural for white to defend the pawn
to pin the knight and then they just get
and then they raise the queen
and then they get made if they don't
take the queen are you is there any way
they can get back here
so there's a couple other variations
this good question
uh because some people will take the
knight
yeah and then
if you wanted to you could take the
bishop and then you you did win back
your pawn
but there's there's a nicer tactic here
you can win white's queen without giving
away your own queen
i guess you take the pawn with the
bishop check
if he eats it you get the queen exactly
he doesn't eat it you probably have the
other bishop check again
very nice yeah that's what we call
that's that's really cool
yeah it's called removal of the guard
where your queen was
attacking white's queen it was guarded
by the king so you remove the king from
from guarding yeah that's awesome and
yeah there's no way white can uh
can hold on to the queen and then
yeah then you're just up a queen your
queen is very powerful
from the back rank yeah i only i only
saw that because uh
i i do this really silly play versus
like when when white opens with
d4 i there there's like i don't know
whose video it was it's a really fun
sequence where you just take the queen
early
yeah i think that was probably one of my
videos
um yeah it might have been yeah i know
exactly where you're that's the one yes
england gambit i kid you not i told my
chat about this
and i said i'm gonna stream chess just
for five minutes to show you a really
cool way to take the queen it took about
two hours to get this to happen
oh that's fine i think your video just
came out and everyone knew it and
nobody was playing into it that's the
problem right
yeah people find out about quickly that
they don't fall into it
every game was literally e4 and i was i
was literally
dying inside well hopefully after
learning some staff or gambit lines
you'll you'll be more
more looking forward to playing e4 we're
playing again this is this is great this
is a lot of fun
yeah so this is only like scraping the
surface
uh so this is um this is one trap where
if if you get this position you are like
every variation
you're going to be winning a lot of
material or mating
there's one more move to just show you
here if white
moves the bishop back trying to defend
then you can take the bishop
and pawn will take back
and your knights still attack white
doesn't want to take the knight but
rather than moving your knight
you can counter attack h5 h3 four
queen queen h4 yeah yeah it's it's
normal to uh
you have to struggle with notation but
uh exactly the right move
because you you hit the king if king
moves up you mate
yeah if g3 you can take the pawn and
there's a pin
and white's position is crumbling that's
a cool one
if here you you take the rook and you're
you're in very very good shape
i did not see that knight move that's
really cool so this is a very typical
pattern whenever white is missing the f
pawn
and the king is still in the center i
always want to be aware of this move
and very often it can be powerful
even if white can block in this case you
were able to take
um so
i was actually um i guess before we
hopped on call i was showing earlier
there's another variation of white plays
f3
where you play knight h5 to prepare the
same tactic
and it's very easy um like if white just
kind of ignores everything
you have the same kind of tactical idea
you check the king
if g3 you take and there's a pin right
and
white is losing some material that is
awesome
so yeah so white has to be very careful
when dealing with this f pawn
even if it stays on f2 there's a
possibility of attacking it
um so let's let's start from the
beginning and i'll show you maybe
a couple more traps sure but i want you
to play black
so just kind of play the opening move
with stafford
make sure it's uh it's being ingrained
in your memory
yeah um let me just remember what it was
here night
great
okay so in this case
i i'll still play d3
defending the pawn and now rather than
playing bishop g5
i'll play knight c3
okay let me see here hmm
and i'll tell you right away knight c3
is not a good move
and it allows you to capitalize and win
back material by force
and your next move is like one of the
main moves that you play in stafford
which um i i did give some clues earlier
so
see if you can remember the idea
if i didn't know anything about stafford
like my instant move would be this
threat and check made go for i don't
know position i don't see
i mean there there is the bishop to e e3
that kind of bothers me yeah queen d4 it
looks nice it is a threat but it just
it gives white the chance to defend and
then you're the one on the defense
and you're not getting i'm assuming it's
g4
yeah this is much better like you have
the right idea to attack the pawn this
is a better execution
because i know you like the knight i
don't see it yet but i'm just
that's what it is well you have two
attackers on f2 you have the knight in
the bishop
and on top of that you're controlling
the e3 square as well with both knight
and bishop
so bishop e3 you'll be able to take and
win a pawn
and the problem for white there's no
effective way to defend f2
without losing something he goes f3
that's i can just move my queen then
right with the check
oh this is this is a good example
because if you um f3 it's weakening
but if you move the queen in then
there's g3 and you
don't necessarily have a um
[Music]
a great follow-up so after f3
even though you're not going to be
winning this pawn you can just dive in
with it
and fork the the rook and the queen well
i didn't even see that dive
well i forgot about the bishop yes
it's one of the main threats like when
you when you threaten knights
takes pawn the more important thing is
that you're forking the rook and queen
which so uh
so yeah white's in some trouble here and
even if like the queen
moves somewhere you still take the pawn
and
life will be very good so it is mostly
there's nobody
like to take the knight if he gets out
of position
um
i moved knight there's no danger here of
me losing the night after
i don't know uh yeah that's a good
example um
in this position your knight's defended
but you probably want to move the knight
you could move back to g4 i would
actually be defined
because it's defended by the bishop
right but you could
actually four
sorry can you repeat that do you ever
bishop the g4 oh bishop yeah bishop g4
is another move
where you attack the queen queen g3
you have to be careful now because your
knight's only piece defending your
bishop
um yeah i was going to say the other
thing to pay attention to your bishop is
now aligned with the rook
yeah so eat the song with the knight you
could take the pawn
yeah on d3 and you lose your knight but
then you win the rock
wow what a crazy position dude that's
that's insane
so there's a lot of like nice kind of
flow
to these sort of yeah tactical
variations where
you just keep you keep attacking you're
taking stuff and sometimes hard for
white to get out of your
sort of grip um
so what most people do in this position
they they play bishop e3
and the they lose back the pawn
and then you have the choice whether to
take with neither bishop
um i usually recommend taking with
knight
because then after takes takes your
bishop is very powerful
it can prevent white from casting either
way i see
and if white attacks your bishop you
leave your bishop there you defend it
with your queen
it's a nice position like the bishop's
ready to come to g4
where would you play the queen there
instead of d4
oh yeah queen d4 so
with queen d4 your queen is a bit more
of a target here
um actually it still looks playable
is there maybe potential for 92
um i guess i can say that queen g5 it
has
the additional idea of bishop d2 check
because you create this battery
because i was thinking like um if you go
here and let's see he goes
just get like oh you can't even you can
go for free pawn right but you could go
after the pawn and hit the rook yeah and
just leave your bishop hanging because
the rook is more valuable
i don't know so there's a lot of ways
like the game can branch out but
essentially
if you if you get this position
with white playing knight c3 and d3
it's already good for you because of my
g4
yeah i see it and it's one of the most
common traps
white can fall into even
there was a game a few months ago hikaru
with the white pieces
stumbled into this position against like
a 1 000 rated player
on chess.com it was one of his like
speed run videos
uh hikaru so hikaru played
he played some crazy move
um i think he played queen f3 here
actually
and after it takes he played
he played some like knight a4
and he was getting crushed in the
opening because after he takes takes he
doesn't want to play queen h4 and won
the pawn
he's still somehow one but opening was a
huge disaster for him
wow that's crazy so yeah one thing i
like about stafford too there is
a lot of like high-rated players that
just aren't aware of it
uh that could very easily stumble into
traps
um so
i'll show you a few more like engine
wise here
who's ahead at this point if we're
playing perfect after this point is
black behind
so the engine will will hate the
stafford for black
like if you if you toggle the engine on
it'll say like plus
almost close to plus two what does plus
two mean sorry
so plus two is equivalent of being up
two pawns
wow so you're that far behind
theoretically which if you don't get any
of your debits
off right but it doesn't
like the engine will just it bases its
evaluation off like perfect
play yeah and it doesn't reflect
the true difficulty to play this as
white and um
there are some lines where even like the
engine doesn't fully understand
as well because like there's so much
depth so
um but like there is some risk involved
where if you're not getting
these specific traps and your opponent
does like manage to develop and cast on
hold onto the pawn you you do run the
risk of being worse
but from my experiences it's worth the
risk because
a lot of the time especially against the
lower rate of players you'll
you'll you'll have some success with the
traps or just like official aggressive
play
um and it's like it's a good lesson to
keep in mind too kind of the
the trade-off between material and
attack and activity um and very often
you can go against what the engine wants
by sacrificing material to get some
early activity
um and to be in the situation where it's
easier for the opponent to
to go wrong
so another common move here
when when you get like the starting
position as
of stafford it's for white to play
knight c3
just again defending one um develop the
knight
and you do the same thing you play
bishop c5
and now what we just saw is um
is basically the position after d3 it
would be
the same thing you play knight g4 sure
what if it goes d4
if d4 that's a nice thing about yeah
yeah i forgot you have the queen open
so another move for white and
this is another like one of the most
common traps is bishop c4
okay we're white's just developing
naturally
just wanting to castle yep uh question
is how do you punish this move
how do you punish this move
so i'm just thinking in terms of
stafford's here but uh
generally speaking is is that even a
problem for me for it to be there
like if the bishop is there can i not
just continue doing the same thing
you can do the same thing yeah it's a
bit different because light can castle
oh okay i see the castle okay that makes
sense but you're yeah
it's good that you're you're just
applying the same same idea
um going after the pawn uh
here very important to play
the next move correctly because
white has enough defenders on f2 but you
can add one more attack i mean
yeah queen h
and now it's it's a double attack yeah
you're threatening made in one
but you also have three attackers now
against f2 pawn
um and
while it's so only it'll say how many
times this has occurred
in in just rated games and
this position has occurred over 5000
games
wow okay black winning the the vast
majority
and um i've had this position myself
a good handful of times uh very often
what happens
white doesn't want to get mated on h2
white will play h3
you can take with the knight hitting the
queen
white will when you're also yeah you're
sitting up to the knight to move and
check
exactly so sometimes white will move the
queen
trying to counter attack your pawn but
you're the first to strike you take
on h3 with double check wow the king has
to move
you move the knight again because you
you discover check king comes back and
then you mate
that's crazy so this um
this exact sequence so basically an 11
move game
has happened 426 times on the chest
so gonna be more soon just just you wait
i'm gonna set that up a few times yeah
it's
it's interesting like maybe a couple
years ago these variations were not so
well known
but uh in recent over last year or
recent months like they've gained a lot
more popularity
um so and again it was like so natural
for white to play all the moves that we
just saw
yeah and then then suffer the
consequences
how do you play against the stafford
than if you're playing
um starting with e4
so there are i mean
there's ways to play against it um
one
like this is already stafford once you
get that double pawn right
yes yeah so this is the starting
position of stafford um
and i mean as long as white doesn't fall
into a trap
usually you can get a playable position
so one example would be
let's say um i'll share
i'll share one of like the best lines
for white is to play h3 here
h3 wow which not too many people know to
play
but this is like one of the top things i
can recommend
for white if you're if you're struggling
with this opening
yeah you can't play the game anymore
yeah you can't really play knight g4
and that was kind of your whole source
of counter play
yeah um there are ways to combat this
move h3 which which i can dive into like
there's always more layers
to unpeel yeah um i was gonna show you
one more i would just sacrifice my
bishop for it
again anyway a sack the bishop yeah it's
uh
um
oh no yeah it's something like you don't
want to get too emotional or reckless
when the opponent plays a move
that prevents you from what you want to
do um
i i can quickly show there's a couple
ways to meet h3
what i used to do uh is play h5
and then if white goes for
[Music]
let's say like can i show this
let's say bishop e2
[Music]
um actually bishop e2 is falling into
yet another trap
um it's one of the deeper traps but here
you have a cool sequence
queen d4 threatening mate there's no
bishop e3 this time
white has to castle and then knight g4
um and that's the whole reason to play
h5 is to support the lights
for when white castles because now if
white takes a knight
you take back and even though you you
just lost a
a full minor piece you have the half of
an h file or the fully open each file
and you're just threatening to mate in a
couple moves
um oh you never go forward with the pawn
after that pawn here's another idea
but just to show you an example line
like let's say white plays d3
yeah after queen e5 white has no good
defense
this is forced me oh okay i saved
uh i'll quiz you in with a move here
let's say g3
what should you play as black
oh that's interesting um let me see
that's a that's a tough one i'm gonna
give you a small clue black to move
check made in one move wait check made
in one move
yes oh wow you're right
yeah wait no wait wow this pond is
pinned
yeah you're right that's insane i showed
something similar in like a youtube
video and
like there's so many comments why can't
the pawn take the queen
but yeah the bishop pins upon so uh so
far
that's true but it plays such a nice
role in in preventing the pawn
because white would want to play f4 here
but that's not legal
i got to get out of that mindset because
whenever the bishop is so far
like my brain just imagines something
must be blocking it
interesting it's not playing a role
yeah it's so important to have um what
we call board vision like see the big
picture
and see especially if a bishop is
aligned
on the same diagonal as a king that can
lead to
like very good things you know correct
me if i'm wrong
uh i i always assume because i know a
lot of top level chess players can play
like
even more than one board blind just not
even knowing
looking at a board i assume that's not
because they can memorize boards but
more because
they're aware of what every piece is
doing so they can just recreate the
board at any point just by knowing peace
position
awareness yeah i don't know i think
that's a good explanation
uh yeah like i'm i'm able to play like
two games at once
without looking yeah and a lot of it is
just recreating
um because kind of everything has their
their logical
placement um and it's kind of this
element of chunking when i played
blindfold chess
i'll consider the whole queen side as
one chunk because this is just such a
common
configuration um i like to compare it to
like visualizing a room in your house
like you you kind of remember where all
the furniture is
yes and you don't need to constantly
think oh where is the bed or where is
the
the bookshelf or whatever you can kind
of go back
and uh and recreate it in your mind um
but yeah when you're first starting out
and um and learning like new different
types of patterns it takes more mental
effort to kind of
to see the big picture and see how
everything kind of
interconnects um
so yeah so the way for white to like
appropriately meets h5 is to play d3
and then um white still has to be
careful but
this is like a better a better approach
against the stafford gambit we went so
off topic um
just to refresh why was where are we
playing h5 again what was the purpose so
h5 it was a bit more
long term so you you create a situation
where if white castles
you'll get this um
[Music]
yeah and this occurs in some other lines
like um
and there's different kind of what we
call move orders or transpositions where
white can
white can play knight c3 first light can
play d3 first
so it's important when you play stafford
to kind of have a
have a tool set of different ideas yep
and then know what to play
like what moment to play which move so
sometimes what will happen is white will
play
um a very safe setup
like this yeah where they prevent knight
g4
and you can use the same idea here to
prepare knight g4
with this h5 move
um and if white plays h3 i'll show you
just another example to try and
reinforce the concept
h3 here can be met with queen d6
okay you're waiting for white to castle
and then you play knight g4 and you're
you're threatening mate on h2 and we can
see a lot of like similar patterns
if white takes and you take um
it's very similar to the previous
position we just saw
i'll quiz you one more time if g3 what
you do
yeah queen yeah yeah i had there's um
some time maybe back over the summer i
had
one one day i had this the same position
three times
and like the same day like everyone was
falling into it
um so it's a very typical kind of
attacking mechanism
um even if if white tries to play knight
or prevent knight g4 you can still
sometimes repair it i i absolutely love
playing black now i'm i'm absolutely
sold
that's great to hear and maybe like what
we can do
um is
play like a few games against viewers
where like if
if we're black we'll request that people
go into stafford just to get some
practice
there's one more thing i wanted to show
you because people were asking about in
my chat
and it's another thing to kind of uh i
guess
to learn if you are gonna start playing
stafford is what to do if white plays e5
just attacking your knight and not even
giving you the chance to play bishop c5
right away
yeah with this move uh it's best
i know knight g4 was like usually the
go-to move but here
it's best to put the knight in the
center okay
where you're still threatening to play
bishop c5
let's imagine like keeps attacking your
knights yeah
d3 is a blunder surprisingly even though
it looks like a really nice move for
white
um you can respond very actively
by leaving your knight on e4 and i'll
show you the move here because
sure it's a bit hard to understand but
you play bishop c5 anyway
and the point is if white takes
black to move and win the queen
yeah check you take the queen right
yeah i assume and then if king u2 you
check with other bishop
very very nice yeah that's awesome so
it's uh yeah it's easy for like these
these patterns to be reoccurring in
different variations and if bishop e3
you can take take
and black to move a similar idea we saw
earlier
very nice in g3
g3 is uh i'm assuming you just
take here right and get the free pawn
and it takes you take the knight right
yeah you take the rook yeah yeah very
nice sorry yeah yeah
so very similar to what we saw earlier
almost exact uh exact same thing
um so it's so easy for white to like
stumble into
into some of these variations it's like
these moves are so natural
now there's another move here i could
try d4
um preventing bishop c5
and then i'll just show you one more
trap you can play queen h4
threatening mate yep let's imagine
white plays g3 yet again
this move is a mistake from white and
you can win material
uh i'll show you the first move is
knight takes g3
yeah now there's this pin but white
could take with f pawn
a block to move and win material yeah
queen e4 and you're winning the rook
yeah wow that's crazy so uh
yeah just just yet another tactic and
then there's like we're only scraping
the surface with like the amount of
like tactics and different variations
but i don't want to overwhelm you like
so much
but just kind of give you um a glimpse
of oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna rewatch your vod
like 10 times because
yeah forget someone for sure yeah
definitely it's good that this is being
recorded i might even put this whole
thing on youtube just like uh just like
a more thorough staffer gambit lesson
um because i have youtube videos where i
explain these like
these traps pretty quickly but not so
much like very kind of slowly in depth
um so i yeah i think this is a good
starting point
uh there's cases where white will play
knight c3
which would require maybe like a whole
other like we could spend like an hour
talking about what to do from this
position
um yeah but uh i usually recommend just
you you copy whites
and i'll show you one thing here
just to give you like some excitement
for this position as well which a lot of
players will walk into
if white plays bishop c4 you can do
what's called the center fork trick
and this is actually a small mistake
because you
take the pawn
temporarily losing a piece but then you
play d5 you win back the piece and you
get some nicer
um yeah no longer stafford but you're
playing for century so this is no longer
staffer this would be a line in the four
nights
um but i don't want to overwhelm you
with so
so many lines um
but that's just a glimpse of of what
else to learn
if if white avoids the stafford
what if he doesn't take the night like
if we're here
like so he goes should i go and then
what let's say he just
oh wait he has to take it right so
you're attacking the knight yeah
so and i'm thinking of pawn as well
you're right
yeah if white moves back then you take
the pawn yeah
and it was just a fair trade uh one
thing to understand here i'll quiz you
here if white plays queen e2
attack your knight and pinning your
knight to your king
what would you do
um i mean off the top of my head i would
just play the pawn but
so this looks like one of the most
natural moves this would actually be a
blunder
because white could follow up with d3
and your light would be pinned and
attacked yeah you're losing material
a lot of material so what you want to do
here is you you you have to defend the
knight somehow but you also
want to break the pin and there's one
move to break the pin and defend the
knights
i'm queen yeah sure queen e7 and now if
d3 you can safely move
and this could lead to a trade but
you're completely fine here
a bit more development don't play d5
next move
so um but that was a good question
because some people will
maybe be scared of accepting the gambit
move back and
then it's just a trade
such a cool position absolutely in love
with the position this is great
yeah it's really fun for me to teach too
because this uh
this is one of the things that keeps me
like motivated to
uh to play so much chess is a the
prospect of having like these fun
openings
um would you want to sometimes what i
like to do with these sort of
collaborations
is have you play a game
it can be like a non-rated casual game
where we can kind of team up and talk
through
the possibilities sure sounds good to me
um it would require you
maybe just accepting a challenge
um all i can do is follow you
i got a i got a challenge here casual
five plus do i accept that
yeah except that uh hopefully it's from
someone
oh oh okay it's from one of my mods
actually this is grace
and he's probably around your level um
or you're able to watch the game so i'm
watching the game
and uh you're you're free to move
uh but
what we can do is kind of discuss like
if there's a moment you're not sure what
to do
um yeah and usually like if you're
playing a raider game you shouldn't get
outside assistance but because this is
like
this casual and we're kind of streaming
it our opponent knows what's going on
um yeah we're gonna have a stafford so i
don't think
uh i don't think he'll fall for a trap
but maybe oh maybe he will
oh wait wait this this was something i
learned wait a second
okay it's all up to you now
oh boy uh i i know we went over this um
i'm pretty sure
it is g4 with the knight but um uh
sure this is the first trap i showed you
yeah when the knight gets pinned you
play a move
which is going to never remember i
forgot yeah
it's good you're taking time here
i'm pretty sure it was this
oh wait it's not it's not
maybe you should ask for a take back
maybe he'll be nice
give me a take back oh he was nice what
a nice guy
yeah i was giving up the queen i'm
trying to remember how i give it up
hmm it was another night move
it was actually or was it h5
oh no you eat the pond you eat the pond
yeah yeah yeah i remember now
oh you might have to hit the take back
button for it to actually go through
where's the take-back button this oh no
wait
i don't even know where that is
i see it that's pretty cool
okay it is the pawn take yeah you're
right
not everyone will be this nice
true so then
here i'm pretty sure it was
um here
you take with check forcing move yeah
amazing yeah sometimes like the way for
this to fully sink in
into memory is to actually get it in a
game
uh oh 100 agree yeah and then hopefully
like next time you have this you you
won't even like hesitate you'll just
know to take the pawn um well thanks
uh yeah that was uh brian brian the
rabbit rabbit
from my chat i was very kind okay so
maybe it was a myth
guys yeah it was uh just an innocent
mouse slip
yeah so if you're getting if you're
getting other
challenges i do have your stream open a
lot of challenges actually
yeah that's the nature these days people
you want to make they just accept
wonders is casual
um they're they're they're all standard
rated
casual okay there's one rate in all or
casual yeah just accept a casual one
completely up to you
all right 1900. oh okay
we're playing uh i know this person
um he's gonna play he's gonna play
strong moves
actually i played him so this is bill
brock
i played him about a year ago and
he played one of the best lines he
played f3 yeah
so do you remember the move i showed
here
i'm trying to remember uh you want to
set up this queen check
so in this spot it was
that was the move oh my goodness let me
think here
yeah putting it to memory is a little
bit hard but i think once you play it
once like sure
i can tell you just to save time is
knight h5 you move your knight to the
side
yeah you set up the queen h4 check
um he's gonna see it he's probably going
to play like
a good defensive move um
but with this variation we want to play
as aggressively
as possible i remember entirely now yeah
because you can just eat the pawn
afterwards after he blocks if he blocks
with the pun
uh exactly yeah when queen h4 you create
the pin and then
uh it's easy for white to crumble
so with this now we still have it let me
think
so i go with the queen there
unfortunately you don't quite have it
because there is um
the white queen can block on f2 oh yeah
you're right
so i'll tell you to trade queens there
to stop his castling
would you never go for that you don't
want to trade queens because you're down
upon you want to keep queens on the
board
to attack so here's you can develop the
bishop
to c5 like the move that you usually
play like very early
controlling f2 to then set up
this uh this tactical idea
okay it makes sense now we can't block
with the queen anymore exactly so now
you're still threatening queen h4
uh you know i'll go g3 now so g3 is the
best move
hopefully he's not watching or extreme
sniping
he's good enough to find this move like
this um yeah for a good player like that
they'll know to do this
and now um you don't have a check i'll
say
like you you want to castle you want a
castle and then get your rook into play
um so there's no more offensive options
here unfortunately
you can't like you can't strike
immediately you're gonna have to bring
more pieces into play
right um it's like d4 does nothing
basically then
like queen d4 oh yeah queen d4 is like
white has everything defended
uh and another reason that you castle is
to play pawn f5 and open the file for
your rook
he's playing this really well though i
see
does he does he take it usually if he
takes it
then you you put you the rook on the
same file as this king no but i'm asking
does he take it
or does he just like ignore it oh he's
yeah
i guess we got the answer he's just
going to ignore it and
attack your bishop um
that was a good move
yeah we're entering the middle game um
where you're like you're castled you
have two minor pieces developed
but he's being kind of annoying with
this like large pawn center
um like b2
sorry can you say that one more time do
you go bishop b2 or
you i i think bishop uh i think you mean
bishop e7
like you move all the way back i've been
b6 sorry
oh bishop b6 so okay yeah there's a
couple options i would probably
recommend e7
um because there's an idea you want to
play f4
um actually both moves
were probably playable there but uh
you want to go f4 so you want to play
pawn f4
to oh target the pawn on g3
and then if if he ever plays g4 you play
bishop h4 check
it's it's kind of a deeper idea it could
very easily get like
messy very quickly but that's kind of
what you want
okay so you're just going to the
offensive with the bishop for that
reason you're just okay yeah so your
your bishop has more access like when
it's on e7 it can access both sides
on b6 it's a little bit out of play it
will be blocked by white's pawns
um so here's the bishop all right
yes yeah so um here's where you go for
f4
yep and you have two attackers
bishop right to check exactly and your
knight supports f4 along with your rook
so true you're you're trying to find
like some nice coordination with your
your pieces
makes sense but i will say like he's
playing this really well so
um there is a chance that we won't get
exactly what we're
hoping for but it should still be fun so
this is where yeah you can deliver the
check
and now we took away so the king is now
going to be stuck in the center you took
away counseling rights
you never have to run with the knight
right now yeah yeah
yep okay so just for the
getting rid of the castling rights
basically yeah otherwise like he would
castle the king would be more safe on
on the king's side
now one goal because like your queen is
aligned with his king
you would really love to open the file
like get rid of this
this pawn on d4 understood
and one way to try and do that is to
play pawn c5 c4
c5 yeah yeah got you and meanwhile like
his queen side pieces are undeveloped
his pieces aren't too impressive yeah
but the impressive thing is
for white is this like nice pawn center
that we really want to start poking
holes in
okay so king c2 that's very logical so
would you still go for it
uh you yeah you could go for a c5
unfortunately it's less powerful now it
might just lose a pawn
um i'd probably recommend like complete
development like play bishop e6
developing towards the center and
at some point you still probably want to
go for c5
yep
that's a type of position that's going
to require some more like long-term
thinking or plans
oh this is interesting so he okay he
just took a pawn which is undefended
yeah what you can do because your rook
is aligned with his bishop
you could remove your knight and take
his
take his g-pawn yeah yeah i like that
and then you you attack the bishop you
win back upon maybe some night left two
ideas
are you very solid
did we trade bishops here yeah i've i
would agree with that trade bishops
oh you have a really cool move i mean
okay i'll tell you right right now
you're gonna play
after he takes your bishop play bishop
oh wait never mind it doesn't work
ah i'll explain after the game i know
you're running short on time
yeah you might want to retreat the
knight and pray
are we retreating to the f h file to f
just to keep uh central keep keep some
control in the center
they're probably gonna get timed here
but that's okay yeah this is how we'll
learn
um yeah feel free to play quickly like
um
you can maybe like queen e7 get your
other rook into play
yeah um
c5 c5 yes if you get c5 in yeah just
blitz them and hope for the best
yeah you like c5
and d5 you'd probably have to retreat
i don't know what i'm doing the c6 is a
great move actually
just challenging the pawn now play b5
still get ready yeah that's okay yeah
i'm out of time
six seconds to go yeah that's a tough
thing about blitz
but it was actually a fascinating game
we went down like um
a critical line
oh you are threatening a tactic here
bishop takes d5 nice move yeah cause the
pawn was overworked
and now you're threatening bishop a2 but
he takes your bishop
my time
like honestly it wasn't so bad uh
i guess time was the culprits true
i do respect the pre-moves though like
i've worked with like a lot of like 20
seconds i'm finished
but most players like don't even have
the capacity to pre-move
um until they reach like a much higher
level so
and like your premiums are very logical
too
i just go with whatever my brain says i
i'm i'm big on
trusting your gut instinct if you have
no better move gotcha
i would have eaten the rook there and
gotten the queen for free right
like take rook he uh he would you could
take that with king or queen yeah
but then i'd check with the other rook
right
and it was good i think he would still
say yeah yeah you're right
well that was fun it was a fun game yeah
i mean we played a very like
knowledgeable player like he was kind of
specifically
prepared for the stafford well if he's a
viewer of yours i'm sure he is prepared
for it
yeah yeah he's someone who i've um i've
played when i
like in a real tournament game when i
was much younger or really
um it was like knows a lot about chess
like very experienced player
um so what what i can do
is we can go over this game in the licha
study
which i sent you in um if you go back to
lincoln discord
okay
um all right
opened just bear with me one moment
okay so i have the game and we just
played yeah
and yeah a lot of this like the the
opening moves were a bit new
so um i guess this is
not something we fully looked at uh
prior
as apart from this idea to play queen h4
and go for this check um but he played
really well like
to put the queen over there and if we go
for the check
um he could even yeah he could play
queen f2 and
it's one thing like when you play a
gambit you don't necessarily want to go
for early trades
especially the queen trade because that
just simplifies the position
even though we take away counseling
rights or is this move
it's just harder to get any attack
against the king
without a queen yet right so
bishop c5 was a go-to move uh
controlling the square
setting up this and how did the game
start again
it went at what point did it deviate so
yeah took took so after yeah obviously
kind of key move not too many people
will play this
yep vast majority of people will play
this this
sometimes e5 but this is like the fifth
most popular move
yeah it prevents my knight from going to
uh g4
yeah it restricts a knight even though
it like it weakens this diagonal
um it's uh it's not a bad move if light
follows through correctly
so we went yeah we basically played kind
of the critical
variation he played a very strong move
here uh to prepare d4
um but okay we still got some
some play what are we
f5 again so f5
yeah and this is um it's a very typical
move especially when the king and queen
are aligned if white takes the pawn
you just oh you pin it we pin the queen
yeah that's smart
so really we we really want to open up
lines for our pieces
when when white is undeveloped and when
the king is still in the center
and usually to open up the position you
it requires pawn breaks
so if you if you're able to trade pawns
and there'll be more lines opening up
um yeah d4 was a good move
i know you you may be more inclined to
play this uh which is probably second
best
but bishop e7 um that gave us access to
the square
and then there is a cool moment
actually this this was nice to like open
the that file hit the bishop
and i was about to tell you to play
bishop c4 here
which is almost really cool because idea
would be if queen takes we fork
oh i see that's pretty cool indeed the
problem is the queen can take
and we can't fork because we're in check
oh rip and we would lose our night next
move
so yeah yeah um
[Music]
yeah so unfortunately had to move back
and then
um yeah it was actually interesting
like around here yeah like your the
moves that you played in severe time
pressure
were quite good um
to get rid of this pawn and then
yeah it was kind of impulse but um yeah
this was an amazing move bishop takes z5
because we've got the clear the rook
spot yeah
you wanted to open the file you're
threatening to take with check and win
the queen
and then if only you took on that five
and if only you had enough time
this would have been better for black
because you win the pawn you attack the
king and you're winning um
winning the d5 pawn yeah
um unfortunately did not go that way
yeah and this is a case uh as with
with playing online games you're going
to lose a lot of games and
as long as you can take a few lessons
away